c'est un peu joyeux se fête des pins
l'expression anglaise et râper blast est
un pis polystar to you
et de bénédiction d une hypothèse qui
patrice est finie et spiritus ans qui
dessinent date super bowl cette manie à
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir ces images
par lesquelles nous avons ouvert votre
journal
c'était celle donc de jean paul ii
s'adressant à la foule de pèlerins
massés place saint-pierre à midi à rome
en plusieurs langues comme il aime à le
faire puis donnant sa bénédiction à la
ville et au monde urbain est au repos ce
dimanche de pâques 1980 présente quelque
chose de particulier en effet cette
année pâques pour les chrétiens
d'occident et pâques pour les chrétiens
d'orient g20 c'est les mêmes dimanche
ainsi les catholiques les protestants et
les orthodoxes et des autres chrétiens
célèbrent la fête ensemble et cela se
produit assez rarement parce que toutes
les églises ne suffit pas même
calendrier
cette année d'ailleurs chose également
rare le temps pascal des chrétiens
correspond au temps pascal des
israélites qui fait en ce moment même la
semaine de la pâque juive
un commentaire de philippe harrouard la
pâque juive qui a commencé lundi soir et
qui dure huit jours symbolise la sortie
d'égypte du peuple juif et donc afin de
son esclavage c'est une fête de
libération dans tous les sens du terme
alors que le peuple conduit par moïse se
prépare à recevoir le don de la torah
qui deviendra la constitution de tous
les hit right pour commémorer cet
événement les juifs ont célébré lundi et
mardi soir les repas du cder tous ces
jours ci ils ont mangé du pain azyme en
souvenir du départ précipité des
compagnons de moïse qui n'avait pas eu
le temps de faire lever le pain les
cérémonies de la panique se termine
mardi soir sauf en israël où elle dure
un jour de moins pâque orthodoxe ici à
athènes
les orthodoxes dans la nuit pascale
reviennent chez eux munis d'un cierge
dont la flamme provient du feu béni dans
les aigus répondant à la proclamation du
pop christ est ressuscité chacun affirme
christ est vraiment ressuscité la flamme
déni est partagée s'est rallumée les
foyers des maisons après quoi une grande
fête rassemble toutes les familles qui
partagent un fit la joie de pain
clac catholiques à rome où jean paul ii
a donc célébré sur le parvis de saint
pierre devant 350 mille personnes la
messe de la résurrection
dans la nuit il avait baptisé 24 adultes
de différentes nationalités dans son
message délivré au monde entier et
transmis par la télévision dans 28 pays
jean paul ii a lancé un appel à tous
ceux qui construisent le monde humain
afin de ne pas repousser le crif et in
poissy asie moto et dix-sept aurez vous
qui de quelques manières et en quelque
secteur que ce soit construisez le monde
d'aujourd'hui et de demain a dit le
saint père le monde de la culture et de
la civilisation le monde de l'économie
de la politique
le monde de la science et de
l'information vous qui construisent et
le monde de la paix ou de la guerre le
monde de l'ordre ou de la terreur ne
rejetait pas le christ qu il est la
pierre angulaire autre qu'un homme ne la
rejette parce que chacun est responsable
de son destin constructeur une des
structures les autres centres extra à la
foule des pèlerins qui écoutait le saint
père s'était joint aux participants à
une marche pacifique réclamant le
désarmement général dans le monde
ronan l'aide aux pays sous-développés et
dénoncé hier la pietra angola il se
confirme que le pape viendra en france
du 31 mai au 2 juin
mais le programme de sa visite fait
encore l'objet de négociations hessel
est certaine sa présence à la tribune de
l'unesco pour un discours qui ferait
pendant à celui qu'il a prononcée en
septembre dernier à l'onu à new york
monsieur giscard d'estaing qui passent
quelques jours à courchevel à 20 mai
jean famille a dit aujourd'hui après
avoir assisté à la messe pascale
je me réjouis que la france soit
prochainement jean paul ii je serai
naturellement très heureux d'accueillir
le pape au cours de sa visite le peuple
français tout entier lui réservera une
réception chaleureuse
le président a ajouté que la visite du
pape revêtir est avant tout un caractère
pastoral c'est-à-dire consacré à la
visite de l'église de france
je vous rappelle que depuis cent
soixante six ans aucun pape régnant ne
s'est trouvé sur le sol de france
le dernier fut
cette pub à la controverse sur les
libertés de nouveau à l'ordre du jour
des milliers de personnes atteintes dans
les ambassades du venezuela et du pérou
que le gouvernement de la havane leur
octroie un sauf conduit pour quitter le
pays
le correspondant de l afp parle de 5000
personnes comprimé au corps à corps et
il décrit le spectacle hallucinant dit
il de ces réfugiés qui espère obtenir
l'asile politique allant jusqu'à présent
fidel castro s'étaient opposées à leur
départ mais hier soir il a changé d'avis
ceux qui veulent partir le pont mais
tout n'est pas si simple
c'est d'après midi on a tiré sur la
foule rassemblée dans les jardins de
l'ambassade péruvienne rien n'est donc
encore joué pour ces familles qui
veulent partir et aller grossir le
nombre des exilés cubains en amérique
latine ou en floride
la floride naujac séguy nous avait
adressé le document qu bourse
le collège chorale way la petite ava qui
part de l'espagnol et qui parlent
l'anglais y avait les canons à neige
tél
ok cubain
ouais les cantos coup valence et les
îles monfreid vous êtes chez vous voilà
c'est ma tante elle a 90 ans et vient
d'arriver découvert il ya quelques mois
seulement révélé sur le centre d'accueil
les plus durs reçoivent un repas par
jour une aide fédérale du gouvernement
et participons momentos allègre du
mercredi les instants heureux du
mercredi et il chante sans le savoir ce
que les cubains de l'île redonne
également aucun d'entre nous a avoué
qu'il aimerait retourner dans l'île cuba
qui à seulement 1 200 kilomètres d'ici
pour l'instant ne veut pas y aller
non je ne retournerai pas avec un
système communiste même pour cette ville
il faut observer que tous ceux qui sont
ici sont pas les capitalistes détester
ou des gens qui exploitent et les
sorties comme on a voulu vendre avec la
publicité la propagande de fidel castro
bien accueillie dans le monde
ici les émigrés sont denses prêté par
les 95 % des travailleurs les uns qui
travaillèrent qu'on va la perdre
il faut allier les sucres qui
travaillait dans nos suicide et qui
constitue aujourd'hui la grande masse de
cette migration qui a créé ici sept
centres de la petite enfance presque un
délicieux restera calme et nous les
copains quoi bientôt assiette assiettes
et nos skis et à vias précédente à la
petite haven les quatre stations de
radio des nouvelles content de parler de
négociations les relations politiques et
croit que ça prendra goût quand ça
prendra du temps et on verra pour les
500 milles cubains de miami négocié avec
castro c'est la fin du rêve de
reconquête de l'île et la victoire de
celui qu'on appelle ici le bourreau et
pour eux c'est l'exil mais aussi la
défaite téhéran et une dépêche afp le
conseil de la révolution a pris ce soir
une décision sur le transfèrement des
otages de l'ambassade des états unis
mais elle ne sera rendu public demain
après avoir reçu l'approbation de la fda
comme inique c'est ce qu'annonce imcd a
dit le ministre des affaires étrangères
qui n'a pas voulu préciser la teneur de
la décision
le suspense se poursuit donc on aura des
informations demain à l'ambassade des
états unis toujours à teyran les otages
ont pu célébrer religieusement la fête
de pâques plusieurs prêtres trois
américains et l'ancien vicaire de
jérusalem monseigneur capucci était
arrivé hier
pour dire la messe ce matin devant les
otages qui ont déjà passé plus de cinq
mois sous la garde des étudiants isla
proche-orient une semaine importante
avec le voyage du président sadate à
washington à l'invitation de jimmy
carter pour débloquer les négociations
sur l'autonomie palestinienne
actuellement dans l'impasse entre
l'egypte et israël ont dit ne pas être
au courant aujourd'hui à paris d'une
invitation qui auraient été lancées par
le quai d'orsay à différentes
personnalités palestiniens de
cisjordanie
c'est un journal du koweït qui a donné
ce maintenant la nouvelle en la
rapprochant en la rapprochant des prises
de position du président giscard
d'estaing sur le proche-orient position
annoncée lors de son récent voyage dans
les émirats du golfe persique
mardi l'invité d'antenne 2010 serait sa
majesté hassan ii roi du maroc
un rendez vous que je vous conseille de
ne pas manquer car le souverain aura des
choses particulièrement intéressantes à
répondre aux questions des journalistes
d'antenne 2 vous savez qu'il se trouve
en france depuis une quinzaine de jours
qu'il a eu avec le président de la
république d entretien qualifié
d'important et que d'autre part il s'est
rendu récemment à rome
oui a été reçue par jean paul ii avec
lequel il s'est entretenu parmi d'autres
sujets de la situation au proche orient
france monsieur francis le blé
socialiste a été réélu maire de brest
au cours d'une session extraordinaire du
conseil municipal réélection dans une
atmosphère houleuse et avec des
manifestants communistes monsieur le blé
avait démissionné jeudi après le refus
des élus communistes de voter le budget
municipal
il avait annoncé alors qu'il voulait
permettre au conseil municipal de sa
ville de reformer l'équipe de direction
de brest avec ceux qui avaient voté le
budget c'est à dire sans les conseillers
municipaux communistes marée noire en
bretagne le gouvernement a décidé le
colmater sans attendre les fuites du
camion avec des tôles doublant tu as dit
monsieur le theule après avoir inspecté
la zone du naufrage
ajoutant ce n'est qu'une solution
provisoire puisque la solution
définitive soit le renflouement de
l'épave soit le pompage des 10000 tonnes
de fuel qu'elles renferment ne peut
intervenir avance un mois la solution
provisoire est coûteuse et difficile
on ne pourra travailler que deux heures
par jour par 87 mètres de fond mais il
faut absolument colmatait les trois
fuites
d'où s'échappent chaque jour
sept mètres cubes de chiots demain à 12h
45 le journal d'antenne 2010 se fera en
direct du laboratoire de la mer que
dirige alain bombard on y parlera
beaucoup de la pollution de la
méditerranée puisque ce laboratoire se
trouvent dans l'île des embiez aise
non loin de toulon voici en avant
première les explications sur cette
pollution par philippe dumez il est
difficile de dire sur ces images un peu
idyllique que la mer méditerranée en
train de mourir mais on se trouve ici à
port cros dans un site très protégé et
ce n'est pas le cas de la majorité de la
côte d'azur
regardez plutôt sous l'eau non loin de
la sortie de l'émissaire du cap sicié
qui sert à rejeter en mer les eaux usées
comme on dit d'une partie de la ville de
toulon il n'y a eu aucune épuration
alors la pollution en base lherbier qui
pourrit et celui ci ne joue plus son
rôle dans l'oxygénation de la mer
quant à la lumière elle a bien du mal à
pénétrer dans l'eau et ce n'est pas bon
du tout il faut savoir que cet herbier
est le véritable poumon de la
méditerranée chaque mètre carré produit
10 litres d'oxygène par jour
le double d'une forêt tropicale
paradoxalement tout ce qui vit sous
l'eau a besoin d'oxygène plus ou moins
certes mais il en faut
si la quantité d'oxygène produit n'est
pas suffisante
toute la vie disparaît et c'est une
véritable désertification
non je me trompe un peu par endroits on
peut voir pulluler une sorte d'oursins
mais ils sont immangeables ailleurs on
trouve ces étoiles de mer noire et pas
sympathique du tout les eaux sûres et on
en compte jusqu'à 20 par mètre carré ce
n'est pas partout aussi grave sur la
côte d'azur mais il est sûrement temps
de prendre des mesures pour éviter
l'irréparable
récemment ici même en 2010 le jeune
chanteur daniel balavoine faisait un
malheur comme on dit en criant bien haut
que la jeunesse ne se reconnaissaient
dans aucun des grands qui occupe le
devant de la scène politique et qu'elle
avait l'impression cette jeunesse
d'écouté lorsqu'il parlait un langage
incompréhensible or actuellement jean
françois kahn s'est ouvert un grand
festival de la chanson y est le
printemps de bourges
l'occasion peut-être pour ces jeunes de
dire en prose du lieu où un de dire en
chansons ce que bella mohammadi avec tom
force ici en prose et justement si on
accorder tant d'importance à ce qu'a dit
un jeune chanteur qui parlait raison de
plus pour prêter beaucoup d'attention à
ce que disent les chanteurs qui chantent
d'autant plus que ces jeunes chanteurs
qui chantent disent exactement la même
chose que balavoine mallory le disent
avec encore plus de violence et avec
plus de fureur encore alors vous me
direz bon ben c'est que dassault n'est
que de la chanson certes vous savez
j'aime je crois que la chanson exprime
quelques fois beaucoup mieux que que
certains sondages par exemple parce qu
elle est spontanée parce qu'elle est
populaire beaucoup mieux que certains
sondages certain état d'esprit qu'il est
difficile peut-être de cerner est il des
exemples historiques le monde joue dans
ce titre est de simplement avant la
guerre de 14
qu'est-ce qu'on chantait vous en
souvenez pas enfin vos parents l'ont
peut-être dit on chantait des chansons
bon comme vous n'aurez pas l'alsace et
la lorraine
comme ils ont cassé mon violon parce
qu'ils avaient l'âme française
enfin les chansons revanchard des gens
sont bénies si les yeux fixés sur la
ligne bleue des voiles à des chansons
anti allemande etc
qu'est-ce qu'on chantait ça vous savez
beaucoup plus que vous chantez en 39-40
alors chantait des chansons complètement
désengagée je m'en foutiste du genre
c'est ma combine ou dans la vie faut pas
s'en faire ou tout ça vaut mieux que la
trappe et la scarlatine c'est exact or
finalement quand on y regarde de près je
crois que ce qu'on chantait en 14 et en
40 explique beaucoup de choses sur ce
qui s'est passé dans les deux cas c'est
à dire sur ce que les fonds fait ces
soldats qui ont été se battre en 14 et
ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait en 40 et bien à
son rôle on peut se poser la question
qu'est ce qu'on chante maintenant qu'est
ce que ça nous apprend et bien toute la
jeune génération de chanteurs chantent à
peu près la même chose et ça c'est très
frappant je crois que ça ne s'est jamais
produit
ce point et qu'est ce qu'il disait mais
ils disent tout simplement qu'il refuse
tout qu'il ya une sorte d'engagement
mais dans le désengagement confond le
temps est bien loin où on se
mobilisaient pour le vietnam ou en
faveur des américains où il y avait
ferrat d'un côté sardou de l'ôta chanson
droite chansons de gauche aujourd'hui
tous ces jeunes chanteurs de quelques
milieux qu'ils viennent chante comme si
la gauche et la droite c'était pareil
l'est et l'ouest pareil le socialisme et
le capitalisme pareil et au fond ils
sont les fils de ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure à savoir cuba d'un côté le chili
blocs l'afghanistan d'un côté le
salvador de l'eau
alors bien sûr on peut dire bon ben
alors cette jeunesse elle n'est pas
dangereuse puisqu'elle est désengagé
mais attention
d'abord il ya quand même derrière tout
cela un air de révolte que ce
désengagement peut devenir une sorte de
nihilisme dangereux c'est pourquoi je
répète que les hommes politiques
devraient prêter plus d'attention à ce
que la jeunesse change est allé en masse
à bourges par exemple mais si demain et
bien ma foi c'est la journée mondiale de
la santé une journée sans tabac
à vous de choisir le tabac ou la santé
les combattants contre la lutte du mal
et que ceux qui combattront le tabagisme
et ses ravages se reconnaîtront à la
fleur qu'ils porteront à la boutonnière
signe distinctif de leur adhésion
et à ce petit badge qu'on distribuera
dans un homme politique connu monsieur
norbert segard ministre des postes
télécommunications qui a longtemps fumée
et qui en a subi les conséquences graves
vous présente ce que j'appellerais tout
bonnement sa confession
j'étais un très gros fumeur je fumais
jusqu'à deux paquets de cigarettes par
jour et je m'étais arrêté de fumer
or c'est par apa gillain sept ans après
on a dû m'opérer d'un cancer du poumon
d'un cancer du fumeur roman levé le
poumon gauche il ya de ça deux ans et
demi ou à et que par conséquent on peut
entre échappée de ce cancer
mais quelle souffrance entre temps que
de soucis non donne aux siens à ses
proches ceux qui vous sont chers
et puis notre père le traitement contre
le cancer mais mal après l'opération est
quelque chose de très dur je devais
subir par exemple des séances de
radiothérapie qui m'en ont provoqué
depuis plusieurs mois ne me l'élite
quand je suis en train de guérir
enfin qu'il me donne une semi paralysie
des membres inférieurs et tout cela
parce que j'ai pris quelques cigarettes
et quand je vois le plaisir que la
cigarette m'a provoqué que les ennuis
que j'ai que je donne aux autres à ceux
qui même en particulier je vous assure
que le bilan est négatif
vraiment je fais appel à tous et surtout
aux jeunes fumer moins mêmes ne fumait
pas d'après les études de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé oms le tabac est le
premier fléau des pays industrialisés en
ce qui concerne les ravages causés sur
notre santé en ce qui concerne des
dangers qui guettent notre santé et il
est devant l'alcool est très loin devant
toutes les autres sources d'intoxication
et dieu sait s'il y en a mais le tabac
c'est aussi pour dire les choses comme
elles sont un facteur économique am
série de chiffres éloquents en france la
consommation annuelle atteint
aujourd'hui 82 milliard d'unités ce qui
représente une moyenne de cinq mille
cigarettes par habitant chaque année
selon des statistiques mondiales de 1976
c'est en pologne qu'on fume le plus près
de 3 kg par an et par habitant
et c'est aux nigériens qu'on fume le
moins - 250 g la france se situe dans le
peloton de tête avec 2 kg par an et par
habitant
pour bon nombre de pays notamment ceux
en voie de développement l'exploitation
du tabac est un moyen efficace de créer
des emplois dans la culture la récolte
le traitement le transport la publicité
la vente bien sûr est un moyen commode
de prélever les taxes en france 72 % du
prix de vente d'un paquet de cigarettes
sont prélevées au titre des taxes en 79
elles ont rapporté à l'état 10 milliards
de francs soit 30 millions de francs
actuels par jour
l'augmentation des taxes peut aider à
moins fumer même si les recettes totales
ne diminue pas moins de fumeurs mais
plus de taxes malgré tout le montant est
encore inférieures aux dépenses de santé
encourus par suite des effets nocifs du
tabac demain donc journée de lutte
contre le tabac l'armée des non-fumeurs
manifestera au grand jour au vu et au su
de tous les fumeurs impénitents dans ses
duels contre la perfide accoutumance au
tabac les combattants se sont donné le
choix des armes
à eux la fleur avec le badge et la
cigarette à leurs adversaires et parmi
les anti tabac on compte gérard majax
qui vous présente sa manière de voir les
choses
et oui ça fait sept mois sur antenne 2
chaque dimanche on montre qu'on peut
transformer une cigarette en fleurs dans
le générique de passe passe c'est vrai
mais d'ailleurs une cigarette chez moi
je ne supporte pas
donc c'est vraiment très aimé pagnon
annonce je supporte pas je suis
dictatorial sur ce point là seulement
mais je supporte pas qu'on fume pas je
ne fume pas du tout et dans l'émission
et qui est destiné au web un jeu nes et
aujourd'hui je ne me permets jamais
qu'on montre quelqu'un en train de fumer
ou qu'ils soient en train de faire autre
chose avec des assiettes qu'un tour et
en même on en montre très rarement
masqué et cigarette c'est quelqu'un ne
peut pas se passer du ciel va ce que je
suggère à nos amis c'est de prendre ses
aises et puis au lieu de fumer
demain quand nous aurons un petit pleure
c'est de faire des tours parce qu'à
regarder on peut faire des choses
formidables désiré sans les fumées c'est
un jeu on peut très bien prendre une
caresse depuis déchiré nassiet mais il a
cassé en deux cela et on remet et de
morceaux jusqu'à ce que la cigarette
soit maintenant intacte la leur ce n'est
pas tout parce que cette cigarette si
vous la placez dans la main en entrant
en bien et bien vous avez la petite
fleur
donc voyez on en revient toujours aux
fleurs toute façon mais c'est plus
amusant 9h05 du suffolk fumée d'empêcher
les jours je veux bien vous croire mais
je dois vrai que je n'ai pas content
en tous les cas demain où nous aider
dans la journée de la lutte contre le
tabac avec la petite fleur dont vous
avez parlé dont j'ai parlé et le badge
d'accord d'accord pour combattre le
tabac et pour combattre aussi peut-être
ce qui fut les aventures culturelles de
georges bégoux nous le montre chaque
semaine paris n'est pas le nombril de la
france en matière d'expression
artistique
une preuve de plus les premières
rencontres de tradition
latino-américaine au piano anne galy je
ne sais pas si france bien une jeune
station des hautes-pyrénées où les
montagnards ont su reconnaître un
tempérament semblables aux leurs
à leurs lointains cousins la cordillère
des andes
les andes au coeur des pyrénées un long
voyage ultra monde pour une rencontre de
deux cultures deux traditions qui ont un
point commun la montagne chilien
péruvien bolivien porteur d'une longue
tradition orale sont venus sur le
terrain pour rencontrer ceux qu'il ne
connaissait pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui
une expérience qui semble avoir réussi
et qui ne demande qu'à recommencer
la campagne a été très positif aussi
bien avec la population qui avec les
musiciens ce qui était le but recherché
de plus nous savons que nous pouvons
renouveler l'expérience l'année
prochaine c'est choisir
vous croyez que les paysans du coin sens
intéressé par la culture
latino-américaine fait pas nous
désintéresser
mais je pense que qu'il n'y a pas mal de
points de ressemblance entre la
cordillère des andes et le curé
pour la trouver l'amitié
une partie des nos gens laissés là-bas
est ce qu'il y à une similitude entre le
tempérament des pyrénéens et celui des
andains comme d'où on dit je pense qu'
il y avait une mission d'étude parce que
c'est les montagnards dur des corses
si on veut dire mais tendre et ouvert
vers de l'intérieur
on en trouve aussi qu'elle est quand
même assez simple les coûts tellement
compliqué donc je pense que la vraie la
portée de tout le monde et ce qui fait
que les uns ici en france
et puisque j'ai pu me passer assez gai
aspirez vous pensez qu'avec ce type de
rencontre de manifestations on fera
sortir un petit peu les indiens comme
vous de l'oubli oui je crois que c'est
important pour nous de pouvoir dire ce
qu'ils ont pas et c'est parce que c'est
aussi importante pour le plus que rock'n
des se rende compte
dès que l'univers indienne elle est
tellement longue que mon différente des
sections pense et peut-être pas la
musique
on aura peut-être des autres occasions
pour montrer aussi l'ensemble de la
culture amour de la tradition orale sur
tout
sport le suédois board toujours lui a
remporté le tournoi open de tennis de
monte carlo en écrasant en finale
l'argentin bill haas en trois sets 6 1 6
0 6 2 le tiercé à auteuil était remporté
par les favoris mais le préféré du
public cache-t-il a été battu par le
cheval le plus courageux d'auteuil noren
boy entraînée par fabre l'homme en forme
depuis le début de la saison et monté
par le jockey cheney ou assis et les 12
cents derniers mètres de la course
nous allons les prendre dans l'année des
fortifications ward et jane casaque bleu
foncé bleu clair même devant un berradja
kazakh rayé blanc et bleu et discours
kazakh rayé blanc et noir coq rouge
oui toi avait été presque oublié par le
staff érodé par le lac édouard legend a
accéléré la lui remettre a fait une
faute au saut de la dernière haie de
l'année des fortifications
il faut du courage pour repartir quand
même casaque orange comme joueur venant
de l'extérieur un bolide cachemire qui
va résolument à la sortie du dernier
tournant
le voici obliqué vers d'avis du pesage
suivez le bien c'est à dire sans aller
sur la gauche de votre écran
on est à 600 mètres de l'arrivée cash
fils qui a peut-être eu tort de ne pas
courir depuis un mois va manquer
légèrement de souffle à l'avant dernier
est c'est la chute de sud encore novice
à auteuil et qui a mal sauté tout au
long de la course au volant
sorento kazakh blanche look rouge va
bien mais c'est à droite de l'écran près
des frênes que vont venir leur hellboy
le futur vainqueur kazakh blancs
ceinture et orange et warwick le final
de la course superbe de la gauche vers
la droite de l'écran il ya quatre cinq
six sept vainqueurs possibles et c'est
seulement aux abords du poteau créé
situation des coptes à gauche casting va
être battu par lauren bay qui galope à
droite tandis que malgré se foutent de
tout à l'heure voire legend gare de la
troisième place une course exemplaire
très disputée avec l arrivée 3 des
chevaux les plus joués par le public
un tiercé favori il en point de temps en
temps 3 h 12
mais justement parce que c'est un tiercé
de favori les calculs des rapports sont
extrêmement long et nous ne les avons
pas encore tout à l'heure vous les aurez
bien entendu au dernier journal de la
journée alors demain réouverture de
longchamp avec entre autres le prix
d'harcourt où l'on verra la rentrée des
deux premiers du prix de l'arc de
triomphe
la jument free très case et le marbre le
tiercé lui se disputent dans un handicap
le prix de présence de 1200 m voici les
pronostics de pierrette brès le 15
d'orbec qui a remarquablement couru à la
mi mars le 6 barback qui court bien au
printemps mais quel vilain non il faut
bien le dire le set routier qui sera
sans doute le premier favori
le cese billy the kid régulier courageux
leucate carlo malgré un point un peu
élevé le 18 mai bulin le neuf
karv ap et le 5 apostolat le temps
demain et bien après une matinée plutôt
fraîche et parfois brumeuse il sera bien
ensoleillé sur la plus grande partie du
pays et les températures seront
agréables dans l'après midi les nuages
seront plus abondants sur l'est et la
corse
mais des averses sont encore à 13
vous avez rendez vous vers 23h avec
gérard holtz qui veut y aura des
dernières informations de la journée
n'oubliez pas notre antenne de midi
spéciale demain de la région de toulon
pour vous parler de la pollution en
méditerranée
et si tel est votre choix nous nous
retrouvons demain soir 20 du pacte à 20
heures ici même bonsoir merci